bonjour bienvenue sur un tel canal tv
des modèles tv l'a eu la huitième partie
il à huitième partie là que tu aimes la
patiente et du championnat du monde
veselin topalov contre vladimir kramnik
donc le score du match j'étais 4 à 3
ouais huitième partie va dire qu'andy
qui pour la première fois depuis quatre
parties elle est blanc oui mais à cause
de cette fameuse histoire de toilette de
l'exécution des sixième et septième
partie nauséabond exact exactement enfin
c'est une histoire donc deux points par
forfaits acquis par topalov suite à une
intimidation fait en menaçant de faire
forfait topalov a réussi à faire forfait
chronique c'est quand même c'était c'est
subtil tout à fait remarquable alors
donc en arrive à cette huitième partie
ou kramnik donc cette fois maintenant
aller blanc après trois fois
effectivement pour les noirs alors sinon
qu'est ce qui t'arrive là haut niveau
pis le là tu viens je me suis fait raser
d'accord je vous fais raser puisque j'en
ai marre des jeux
par contre ils jouent au poker tu t'es
fait raser aussi au poker donc c'est çà
et là varie en fait exactement
non même en fait simplement les cheveux
courts je vous invite à essayer parce
que sapin davantage et assez peu
d'inconvénients donc
si vous avez l'occasion vous allez chez
le coiffeur vous demander 3 mm la
tendance haussière aussi ça prend 10
minutes
même pas ça prend cinq minutes ça a
besoin de champions et en suit d'assez
bon vous êtes tranquille pour mon petit
bouton home et c'est moins cher aussi
c'est également moins cher ce qu'une
coupe et les cheveux tout c'est à peu
près donc
7 mm par mois nous quand vous coupez à 3
mm et vous avez pendant au moins trois
mois tranquille si vous voulez avoir des
cheveux d'un centimètre et demi de
centimes
l'agression avait un peu plus loin 4 5
cm alors vous pouvez faire aussi des
implants capillaires
alors c'est c'est assez subtil alors
mais ça marche c'est que vous pouvez
acheter des cheveux et voulait faire
greffer sur vos donc sur le qr qui font
ça sur la branche a vu sur les cheveux
on se fait greffer des cheveux sur les
cheveux les chemins avec une pinte qui
permet justement de que ça se voie pas
d'accord quand vous en avez 20 c'est à
dire vous pouvez vous faire greffer des
vosges peut arriver comme ça la
prochaine émission comme ça ils pas la
différence et je peux retourner chez le
coiffeur et on va m'enlever des cheveux
et on les garde on peut pas bien pour
les cheveux et un droit de garde
j'ai un regard pour les cheveux et donc
on peut avoir les selon il faut qu
ensuite mail à mes cheveux sont trop
courts pour que je puisse me faire faire
les intentions enfin bon je vous
inviterai d'accord c'est important quand
même de voir ça je pense que tout le
monde
tout le monde ici est consciente
faut quand même comprendre pourquoi le
présentateur préfère je suis au courant
sinon à prendre se pose des questions et
qu'est ce qui se passe et ce que nombre
d'explications pour les secours elle est
très simple qui est que c'est une
pratique c'est plus pratique
exactement alors on va revenir sur le
sol turc sur ce championnat du monde
évidemment alors moi ce que j'ai noté
quand même au delà de cette histoire
mais je peux peut-être juste avant
stéphane on peut rappeler que vous
pouvez vous adonner
oui on passe à l'attaqué comme une télé
pour avoir des belles remarqué combien
de 10 watts et ses enfants kevin r je
veux dire c'est avons jamais exactement
tous les détails sur les cheveux parce
qu'elle n'aura d'autre on va on va
parler après de la masse graisseuse et
on va accueillir rennes vient d'être
voix de bien-être et ses vacances assez
les chaluts ccd plus d une halte et v sa
cellule par ailleurs et donc on peut
s'abonner et on peut s'abonner on peut
s'abonner
donc faut pas hésiter c'est que dalle
tv.com en même temps vous apprenez un
jeu d'échec on vous apprend aussi toutes
les secrets de la lotion capillaire et
de ce genre de trucs donc voilà donc
c'est un truc à savoir alors je voulais
revenir sociaux du monde sur le fait que
quand on a une pression on l'avait
remarqué que kramnik a l'air très
décontracté toujours souriante c'était
en marge de cette histoire d'ailleurs
d'attac d'attac
or échiquier de l'équipe topalov qui l'a
poussé à faire un forfait alors que
topalov lui non seulement ne déclare
rien et saidal nile off qui parle en son
nom mais en plus ça a l'air extrêmement
concentré et déterminé de son côté là il
a pas l'air de vouloir ni rire ni
ni penser à autre chose que kaka c'est
parti et à gagner le match
oui c'est ce qu'on a dit sur l'émission
précédent c'est clair que les skins
topaloff
lui il joue aux échecs et dan hay
l'offre il s'occupe de tout ce qui n'est
pas sur l'échiquier
donc en fait l'équipe topaloff est bien
structure donc dur quoi faire aussi
alors je pense pas que ce soit un souci
principal pour risques on tape à l'oeil
dans ce match n'était pas le fruit des
parements concentrer sur l'échiquier
danilov il s'occupe de monter les
petites affaires décès de tueur troublé
perturbé venir en aide par des moyens
qui sont pas très sportif
pas très fair play mais il faut re sujet
oui oui alors limitant le problème c'est
qu'ils tapent ils attaquent la nouvelle
chronique sur le sur son point faible et
donc à mon avis son manager dans ce
match puisque dans le monde ça devrait
être un duel de manager pendant que
critiquer topalov joue aux échecs
dadonov écarté n'sele devrait s'écrire
des lettres sont les des courriers mois
des commissions d'éthique
les chauffeurs ça tapait dessus voir se
taper dessus mais les deux autres
devraient jouer simplement à chaque et
vladimir kramnik à ses petits travers
c'est qui va trop il va en avant du t2
voilà c'est pas normal qui est tombé
dans le piège il est perturbé un peu
tombé dans le piège
exactement il y avait perturbé le bon
c'était un match sur deux tableaux les
parties d'échecs ne sont pas tes ce
conte c'est à dire qu'on a d'être un
travail parti comme on a pu le voir tout
au long de ce match
évidemment cela a continué avec celle là
qui est quand même pas mal du tout non
plus mais je pense que vladimir kramnik
effectivement un double handicap c'est à
dire que non seulement leïla concept
fatigué et chicken mans parce qu on sait
qu topaloff est qu un super athlète que
topalov sur les fins de tournoi il est
en général il est injouable il chauffe
quand elle est un diesel topalov alors
que vladimir kramnik lui a tendance à
faiblir en plus cela vladimir thermique
a subi tout ce poids de trucs extra et
j'y tiens
lui-même dans l'arène et donc ça devrait
d'une fin de match difficile par le
point fait utile le manager mais
peut-être aussi le point faible de crâne
x et son antenne son honnêteté finir il
est tellement au dessus de tout soupçon
que cette attaque ne peut que le
déstabiliser lui qui n'a jamais eu la
même même l'idée de tricher dans sa
carrière je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord c'est pas je pense je pense que
la livre tandis qu'à la tête sur les
épaules c'est à dire que il sait bien
que c'est ces provocations du camp
d'opale of ces soupçons ces rumeurs
donc lancé par par dan idof sont
absolument pas crédible le cic que tout
le monde le sait que le public est
derrière lui oui normalement ils
devraient vraiment pas être affectés
dans les patins facture est donc ce que
je comprend pas sa réaction de vouloir
se justifie ainsi twitté devrait plutôt
laissé courir ou laisser son manager
s'en occuper en tout cas une mauvaise
réaction de la part de vladimir kramnik
du camp granit est mal gérée peut-être
effectivement qu'on le disait de la
dernière émission peut-être ce manager
quarantaine celle qui a quand même un
certain une certaine expérience n'a pas
encore l'expérience de ce genre de
combat disons inhabituel or or board
or à chiquer et que et qu'il s'est
lui-même s'est laissé déborder c'est
vrai que il aurait dû s'occuper de ça et
dire à kramnik t'occupe pas je n'en
n'occupe aucune photo du jeu et je vais
m'occuper de tout ça mais bon alors
voilà on va revenir maintenant sur le
jeu et sur cette huitième partie tout de
suite
ok donc tram ni que récupère les blancs
a pris trois fois les noirs puisque il
ya eu cet épisode où il a perdu par
forfait avec les bleus en plus ce qui
n'est pas un cadeau et maintenant non
qui démarre cette partie cette huitième
partie y mène au score par 4 à 3 et il
aimera toujours avec des quatre et on va
revoir encore une fois la défense slave
en tout cas le début qui correspond à la
défense là après ses 6 voilà donc on va
pas on va pas c'est évidemment sur
l'explication de ces coups qu'on a déjà
expliqué carl f 3 4 6 et notons que
cette fois ci c'est venir chronique qui
allaient blanc met donc en fait là les
deux joueurs jouent la même ouverture et
que les deux couleurs voilà que plan
sens des slaves et slaves avec les
blancs comme un cadre à carrer les c3 et
l'arc 6 donc là encore une petite femme
variation par rapport à ce qu'on a vu
dans la dernière partie
oui alors au cices ici alors ce qu'on a
vu dans les dernières parties il
beaucoup beaucoup de petites subtilités
là c'est ce qu'on appelle la subissent
la pétition grossistes maintenant le fou
ne passera plus et on n'a pas vraiment
comme projet de prendre en c4 du moins
on a projet mais comme les blancs
peuvent jouer 3 enfin si on voulait
pendant ces quatre yeux le faire tout de
suite ici
ce qui se passait deux grands coups
possibles notamment donc le coût qui a
été jouée c'est le groupe 2 3 qui fait
des smiths lave on ne peut plus
classique et le beauf ou g5 qui est la
variante disons ambitieuse la vente un
peu chaudes où il y as après atout
france et 4 le combi botanique qui est
née complexité incroyable
oui alors on va jouer eux quatre tout de
suite voilà c'est un b 5 n'ont peut-être
empêche le pian et la pouf on attaque le
cabellec louer acheter ce dont ne perd
pas de pièce parce que le peuple ou et
entre attaques sur le fond d'un cavalier
plongée 5 c'est qu'on va s'arrêter là
instruments complexes
c'est une diversion et les plus
compliquées des échecs évidemment les
deux joueurs sont très bien entre paris
connaissent très bien cette pression je
sais pas si c'est redonner sa mais en
tout cas ça aurait été assez saignant
vladimir kramnik dans cette position
donc quel choix rapide entre fous g5 qui
peut donner des trucs super tendu où le
tranquille e3 et il se décide à jouer
plutôt autre coin plutôt tranquille de
manière chronique pour l'instant qui
gère son capital avance donc a été
réduit par ce point forfait mais pour
l'instant topalov n'a pas gagné encore
une seule partie alors caraïbes et 17
à noter qu'il restera que quatre parties
après ça ira donc on s'approche quand
même de la fin il faut recto palausse
réveil oui oui oui les temps pour
topalov de se réveiller oui parce que
c'est vrai que oui baby 2 tu as tout dit
stéphane le score le match approche de
la fin monia deux parties moins il ya de
chances de se refaire car les bds est
donc logique développement logique
laisser le fusil du grand classique sous
des trois toujours temps de prendre une
fois que le fou est développée donc on
prend ces quatre maintenant il faut
penser 4 et b5 le coup logique aussi
comprendre l'espace allèles dames et une
fois que le four à bouger et on pourra
notamment développé ce fou sur la case
bessette ou après ses cinq plus tard et
bien il aura toute une belle diagonale
sa disposition alors une remarque sur
cette position stephen court un peu vous
reprendre tout le sens de la lutte qui
va se passer ici
les noirs ont décalé développement du
fouet fuite et ils vont laisser leur 1,8
assez longtemps alors que les bleus vont
recueillir rapidement ensuite les noirs
vont essayer de jouer ces cinq pour
échanger les pions ils vont profiter de
leur avantage d'espacé avec l'option 2,5
donc devant jouer à 6 puis ces cinq
échanges et le centre
donc au niveau de la structure de pions
les noirs sont un petit peu mieux ils
ont dû développement en retard parce que
le roi et le fou en rester là pendant 18
ans et pour les blancs et bien il faudra
réussir à transformer cet avantage de
développement en quelque chose de
concret donc pour cela régulièrement on
essaie d'avancer le pion aux 3 4 puis 2
chassés de cavaliers attaqué sur le roi
donc grosso modo les blancs sur le long
terme n'ont rien mais simplement il ya
une avance de développement qui va
falloir convertir sous forme de gags
forme d'autres choses voilà un que
grosso modo les enjeux de cette smith là
bas alors x 2 x 2 c'est pas le con
principalement rempli du fou le groupe
principal était fou d'être fou des 3
plus tôt donc contre farouk alors foot
bessette
voilà donc la fameux faut évidemment
même temps que ces bouchées de ce côté
eh bien on va sur l'autre diagonale ici
et effectivement il faudra d'abord joué
à six pour protéger les 5 et ensuite
peut-être ces cinq pour libérer seront
notamment et échanger des pions centre
voilà l'idée des noirs est essentielle
si les blancs à empêcher ce plan
or un avantage petit rock b4 donc on
attaque le cavalier roulement pour
augmenter le contrôle de la case ou 4
notamment
ça empêche justement 4 aussi exact c'est
d'ailleurs justement pour ça que
normalement il faut en d3 plutôt quant à
eux deux ces récits de football en étant
d'être ans on répond à des quatre parcs
et valeo 4 l on aurait pu être le cas
ici mais xavier ne peut pas l'en peut
pas donc obligés d'aller en a quatre et
c'est pour ça que tu n'as pas l'offre à
jouer beckham parce que le cavaliere a
car et quand même sur le bordelais qui
il est il est loyal un bis contrôle -
une case évidemment cote ici puisqu'ils
contrôlent un deux trois quatre cases
maximum qu'aux mondiaux des couleurs
huit cavaliers au bord qui avait d'abord
en caméo pour caler mon rang c'est pas
tout à fait vrai examen mais c'est vrai
qu'il est pas super actif ce qu'ali si
on aurait préféré l'échanger contre le
ton qui contrôle parfaitement lesquelles
ces cinq donc voilà ça va se jouer
par contre l'avantagé la hâte que ton
preuve voilà cercle avantage ici c'est
que le plan de libération semble
difficile maintenant pour les noirs mais
mais en fait les noirs en profite pour
jouer tout de suite c'est 5 profitant du
fait que le cavalier et le fou ici
contrôle un peu cette case qui suffit à
pouvoir jouer c'est simple puisque ces
attaques et que deux fois
logique aussi pour les normands qui
profitent de ce déplacement de fou en
deux et non pas en d3 1 pour pour jouer
ces variantes et après pions prend ses
cinq évidemment reprendre cavaliers pour
éviter de donner la paire de fou oui on
a repris ici et c'est là alors là déjà
premier grand carrefour de la partie
donc la cm pourtant il ya déjà plusieurs
options pour cramique c'est dans cette
position
oui lesquels alors bon évidemment il a
coup de la partie qui est l'exploitation
immédiates de la diagonale qui a été
ouverte récemment par l'avancée c6 c5
c'est à cette diagonale alors emprise
donc le premier truc c'est fou mais cinq
échecs
évidemment ça c'est un premier coup
ensuite il ya d'autres possibilités
notamment on peut jouer par exemple qui
est français 5 avec l'idée d'un mât
quatre échecs
notre autre façon d'exploiter un peu
cette diagonale
on peut aussi jouer un coup normal genre
sous des deux bouts des doigts qu'elle a
pas si mal pour attaquer plein week end
donc de toute façon il ya beaucoup de
possibilités
la seule chose que j'aie carteret à la
limite c'est le coup eux 4 qui est
thématique un coup qu'on a envie de
jouer mais ici qui a pas d'argent
le cac est aussi une possibilité qui a
eu lieu au 56 pourquoi pas grâce donc
beaucoup beaucoup de façon d'essayer de
transformer ce petit avantage de
développement et développement parce
qu'on à retiers déjà notre est à l'abri
en plus on a dit m sur cette diagonale
donc il ya beaucoup de possibilité
d'essayer de transformer mais pas
forcément qui marche
ça participe aux échecs c'est toujours
très délicat et la foulée cinq acres à
mickaël riffaut b5 échec au roi et voilà
donc la déjà les noirs ont des problèmes
puisque on ne peut pas mettre le fou
déjà il ya emprise évidemment qu'il faut
revenir ici sur la caisse 17 revenir
savez ce que l'analyse soit avec celui
ci donc c'est toujours désagréable ce
genre de
du coup alors que topalov choisi car les
cds c'est donc si on revient et on
revient à la maison et la chronique
c'est un coût qui fait peur choisi un
coup qui fait plein effectivement
cavaliers ou cinq maintenant augmentant
la pression sur la case 17 pardon sur le
ps 17 avec la dame alors on peut noter
tout de suite qu'ils ont une erreur de
débutant je dirais qu'il faut pas faire
ce serait le coup à six cas la logique
puisque ça tacle veut dire au moins on
va échanger temps fou et j'aurai plus de
problème de clouage mais non ça marche
pas pourquoi parce qu'on ferait fou
prend 17 cavale et prend 17 et
maintenant pourrait même prendre de la
dame par exemple et après d'âpres en
cavale et prend on remarque qu'après
leur apprend qu'il faut qu'ils aient
forcé et bien y'a lapointe finale
cavaliers b6 échec et je vais prendre la
qualité puisque le pion des pulls un
examen donc la petite pointe qu'il faut
surtout pas rater
je dirais que bombes classiques
classique mais je dirais que c'est
tentant les découvre un pour un joueur
un peu débutants de jouer ce genre de
coups et bien fait attention à bien tous
calculs et surtout quand vous avez comme
ça ce genre de calais qui peu après
bondir sur les casses faible c'est
toujours responsable de jouer un pion si
ça en fait on affaiblit des cases
ici on est en train d'essayer de museler
ce qu'avait dit à 4 donc il est
important de garder ce qu on s est
d'autant plus que la vente avec à 6 et
bien effectivement perd tout de suite
c'est pas un bon argument de poids
pour ne pas jouer alors topalov donc a
bien vu qu'assis marchait pas et donc
qu'ils foutent dames c'est cette logique
puisqu'il veut pouvoir éventuellement
ramener sa tour en défense ici en des
huit pour bien contrôler cette case et
en même temps cette dame ici attaque le
câblier donc y gagne un temps sur le
cavalier c'est un coût de développement
logique finances jouer une troisième
chose tu es fan c'est que se prépare
aussi la sortie du fou sur la caisse des
six ça sort ça prépare aussi la sortie
de fosse aux caisses des 6 et être
encore une fois qui vit aux cinq qui
permettra de re ok et qui bouchera un
momentanément la colonne voilà et on
voit que les blancs ont un problème
puisque ce cavalier c'est pas facile de
défendre c'est à dire que soit voilà il
faut prendre soin on prend 17 enfin il
ya plusieurs possibilités soit on prend
17 soit on défend avec la dame soit on
défend et maintenant avec le pion mais
on n'a pas envie de jouer ce coup
puisque ce coût à faiblir et notamment
cette grande diagonale ici vers le roi
blanc et le pion et 3 qui serait
peut-être un peu faible mais efficace et
un coup de serre sans gloor et à la
partie mais c'est possible c'est quand
même con possible c'est vallejo contre
freyssinet je pense où il ya eu un f4
similaire pour bien défendre le cavalier
aux 5 pour un prix de banque vous en
prie de bordeaux avec de cette année un
jour un peu plus dont quelque 400
possibilité ouais c'est intéressant mais
néanmoins j'aime pas trop et je préfère
d'amd 4 à noter que j'aime pas du tout
qu'ils avaient prend 17 évidemment
stéphane calais prend 17 puisque ça
simplifie et dans le travail défensif
des noirs ouais après qui va les prend
on voit que maintenant il ya plus de
pièces blanches à l'attaquant très peu
le prochain coup des noirs ça peut être
cédé 6 autour des 8 peu importe les six
attaquants h 2
ou alors tourner vite pour bien protéger
et après on va baisser les salaires dur
pour les trans et bi semaines durant
donc ta face que le passé déjà parce que
ce fonds est mal développé exactement
ces problèmes là toute façon faut
toujours regarder le coût de 4
la fosse grâce à christine action
pratiquement n'importe quel moment dans
ce genre de position et ce coup il faut
être prêt à sacrifier un pion pour
sortir le fou mais bon c'est pas trop ce
camp militaire chronique alors d'un des
quatre protège le cavalier garde la
pression sur 17 éventuellement propose
un doublement de pièces courtes pour
attaquer fortement 17
voilà une possibilité et le coup logique
des noirs tour des huit logique dans le
purin 7 dans le pion à 7
effectivement kiki qui semble être le
bon coup de prendre le pion à 7
alors non non c'était pas tour des 8
cylindres peut pas dire ça quoi si ça
semble d'être beaucoup c'est de prendre
ses pions parce que c'est un quand même
qui officie en prison comme on dit tout
sacrifice
la meilleure façon de réfuter un
sacrifice est accepté on dit ça on dit
aussi qu'il faut qu'on les tue on quand
ils sont au centre
le plan c'était pas super qui rend quand
on peut le voir d'ailleurs on est
nombreux que les normands par ok non
plus donc là justement on peut regarder
par zenden province est là on peut aussi
doubler les liens et les pièces lourdes
pour mettre une matière de pression sur
17 mais ça ça ne mèneraient après après
a6k qu'un échange généralisé sur 17
la menace et noircissant fait la menace
et à six puisqu'il ya plus de fourchette
la tour est en partie donc effectivement
et on peut voir lors imaginant
d'apprendre c'est l'idée essentielle
c'est que après dan franck cavallier
évidemment on fait d'un profond donc
faudrait pas jouer ça avec les noirs nos
questions j'aurais food et 6 5 des 6
pour attaquer ce qui est bio 5 toujours
d'appeler avec derrière le plus rage de
on voit que le cavalier aurait du mal à
revenir puisque le fou ici pourrait le
prendre à tout film on pourrait mais
simplement ce qu'il faut mentionner
c'est que donc ici par exemple après 4
alors après f4 pour tenir la position
est bien les enjeux petit rock
le tireur est maintenant on s'arrête et
on regarde cette position donc le cap
des 2,5 va pas pouvoir rester là
voyons voir partir des pros sont pas
malins il ya trop sous pression qui peut
s'échanger les noirs ou protéger le roi
et c'est terminé les deux fous noirs
sont braqués sur le roi blanc d'oeuf ou
ici qui sont braqués sur le roi et donc
on a juste
je pense que les compensations sont
largement suffisantes en plus la dame
blanche on a sept
elle est belle ma place et se suivront
pas mal placé mais elle est en danger il
ya des tours à vide qui peuvent arriver
des choses comme ça donc ici c'est un
sacrifice d'options de topalov je suis
certain que vestine topalov narrateur de
cette spécialité d'accord donc tu prends
que tu penses que james bradley a été
sage est trop je trouve dangereux et
donc kramnik a joué un truc plus plus
soul
il a joué fou des deux n'est bon des
fois jean lesage ça peut créer des
problèmes alors fou prendre b4 et la
menace évidemment évidemment mais ça
pourrait être la banane ça peut être la
menace est une menace c'est pas évident
ben faut combiner un tueur fou prend
fout toujours il faudra intercalé
cavaliers pros client d'abord menace
d'avoir cavale et prend cavaliers et
ensuite faute de pouvoir la carte
alors oui la pression est encore
théorique position est encore théorique
à 2005 d'un à cinq plus ou moins la
nouveauté
voilà le coup de topalov donc l' attaque
le fou et souffre ou aller puisque
derrière le cavalier aussi attaquer donc
pas évident de pour défendre et le seul
coup en fait est joué par kramnik mais
c'est à dire il y avait pas vraiment le
choix les fossés sont rentrés dans une
baraque compliqué fusée si ce qui pose
un problème puisque près foot rendre fou
même cavale et prend on va prendre
d'abord le cavalier et après la prise de
balle va gagner au moins là on te
regarde et on peut regarder ces périodes
là on va regarder de leur vie très
importante francs fou prend fou qu'elle
valait prend fourchette cavale et prague
alors attaque dames et tour mais c'est
pas grave se disait de moi puisque je
viens d'abord un cavalier qui vient pro
tour des vite car les pro tour des buts
j'en prends il faut prendre évidemment
sinon le cavalier aurait certainement
des possibilités de sortir et maintenant
ici il ya beaucoup de possibilités
d'attac et le meilleur coût et en a
trois à 3 tout simplement qui menacent
de jouer à prouver qu à en appréhender 4
et a pris la tour va se réveiller sur le
pion à 7 et avec
grosse attaque contre le roi l'énorme
problème des noirs dans cette pétition
c'est le roi le roi des huit qui va pas
pouvoir se réfugier comme il faut un peu
plus rock et qui va vers des soucis on
voit bien d'ailleurs qu'on peut même pas
boucher puisque la dame ici prendre
iliad un adverse
donc on peut même pas même si on
attaquait par exemple la dcri n'ont ici
jouer très certainement comme 4 par
exemple pour garder un oeil sur la dame
ici et au prochain coup on va prendre
d'ici là plus libérant tout les colonnes
avec le roi ça va être très difficile à
défendre donc topalov ne rentrent pas
non ça ne marche pas c'est à dire que
sont fous ces six on peut pas jouer faux
profond ses enfants car chaque voilà
donc topalov j'essaie de jouer plus
beaucoup plus il faut faire preuve de
subtilité parce que la menace apparente
c'est quand même fou qu'on fout d'eux
des blancs la food à voir cavaler
prendrait vallier et ensuite pour un fou
qui prend la paire de fou donc ici c'est
très très critique
mine de rien ces critiques c'est
extrêmement triste mais un coup voilà il
ya un très joli coup que vous d'un cèdre
stop à la fed ait vu depuis longtemps
fo cette randonnée pièces dans la
qualité fait son annonce de décès semble
donner une pièce afin de ne pas pièce
puisque après il faut prendre son volant
le gars réalisent donc en fait on donne
tout simplement donc il est tranquille
et topaloff
et il menace entre guillemets enfin il
va vite faire ok pour laisser les blancs
devant un problème de visas vis entre
tour d'anne et derrière en fout ça va
créer d'énormes soucis exactement alors
le problème des blancs maintenant c'est
que ils ont deux pièces attaqué à la
fois le fou est donc le cavalier qui est
défendue par le fou est donc là on a
l'impression quand même que le cou b3 ce
coup là ici est nécessaire et suffisant
il faut défendre ce qui veut dire qu'à
nécessaire et suffisant puisque ça
contrôler le cas il ya quatre imaginons
maintenant petit rock et l'on se rend
compte que le cahier 17 n'est plus
défendu donc on pourrait maintenant
échanger tout simplement d étayer prompt
les noirs concernent un petit avantage
on prendre ici avec une pièce de plus
pour l'instant mais on voit que ça dure
pas tout simplement poussé 6 peut-être
un petit avantage encore pour les noirs
puisqu'après cavalli c5 qui protège tout
simplement prendre du fou oui et après
la prise de la dame de la gamme d'un
programme ça me prendra les parents
d'amy toujours quelque chose on s'en
fout il ya comme une tour qui est bien
placé le coup contre le coût normal
c'est à trois tout de suite pour activer
cette tour éviter que la tour soit en
évidence une prise ici et là nul de
l'annuler probable puisque après à 5
puis on prend b4 on sera ambitieux
stephen on à la presse le sujet non mais
c'est important quand même de montrer la
fin de la variante je pense que c'est
rendre qui étaient analysées quand même
longuement sur cette poésie et qui avait
dit aussi je suppose cette partie voilà
c'est à dire qu'on va on va mettre
mettre la pression sur ce pion et on va
arriver à changer ses deux pions ce qui
va conduire à la nulle exactement c'est
important de pouvoir échanger ses deux
pions parce que sinon ça pose quand même
problème avec cette tour active voilà
donc on revient ici à la partie est en
fait ici kramnik choisis sur fou hausse
est finalement de rentrer dans une autre
note oriente qui va qui va quasiment
forcé là
une variante où il va y avoir une
différence de matériel s'avère en fait
une des symétries qu une asymétrie une
asymétrie chercher le terme j'arrive pas
à le trouver une asymétrie de matériel
ce qui est toujours bon mais après du
coup en faveur de celui qui veut gagner
oui alors comme on l'a dit stéphane le
groupe b3 était le cookie et les forces
et les nuls les 300 me forcer la
nouvelle a dit mercredi qu'il préférait
jouer tours fc 1 qui est donc le secoue
tours fc 1 qui conduit à une position de
manière forcée avec deux pièces contre
touré pions on va voir la partie par le
rapporteur les noirs en pas vraiment de
coup la serre qui sont un peu coincé
parce que la maintenance sur petit rock
la prise en dix-sept devient réel quoi
et louis dans les gens n'y a pas le
choix il faut prendre ces six voyages
comme petit rock est possible wikio qui
est envisageable en tout cas pas ce
qu'est ce que 17,6 me serais 1 800 la
suite serait pas reprise par exemple
carrefour prend oui ça va tu as peu
préparée de toute façon toutes les
grandes forces sur la très probable sauf
que la tour maintenant est ancien
c'était exactement ce qui est un peu
mieux b3 de bon alors donc turquie était
était possible mais topalov maintenant a
décidé de rentrer dans que ça
remplissait plus la même tendu
puisqu'elles font recette
il est plus obligé de prendre des beats
avec le roi comme on va le voir
justement c'est exactement ce qui va se
passer
eh ben vous pour vous et maintenant il
faut prendre ou donc c'est plus la même
variante cavaliers prend et après d'un
point cavaliers cavaliers pro tour on
reprend du fou donc le roi va pouvoir au
quai exactement et maintenant il ya
quand même
mais il ya une vraie asymétrie matériel
c'est à dire qu'on a une tour face à
deux pièces de khalidié en languedoc de
cavaliers si on considère que le fou ici
est en balance avec le foie de l'hers
alors il faut voir dans cette position
là possibilité qui serait bien pour
pour vladimir kramnik ces flambées cadre
le groupe on a envie de jouer ou normal
puisqu'on garde la dame on garde les
dames et puis on met le fou pour
empêcher le requin empêche le roi que je
suis ton empêche le rock nous ferons
mais quatre ce serait bien mais le proc
simplement un jour là à ces réalités à
saint-éloi à 5 wade a simplement semblé
avoir vu qu'ils avaient des 5 mai à 5 à
l'air de fonctionner très bien aussi a
s'est inclinée c'est le faux est attaqué
et qu'une fois qu'il bougeait bien en
échange les dames et une fois qu'on ait
changé les dames
ça va bien on perd ça va la partie va se
jouer la can deux pièces contre une tour
c'est toujours un petit avantage
maria qui ont ils bien qu'ils vont
gagner en fait c'est des pétitions qui
sont menacés borderline assez équilibrée
parce qu'une tour ça vaut cinq points
puis en savons un point deux cavaliers
ça va ou 3 et 3,6 donc c'est six points
chacun ça se joue à l'activité du canton
sagesse que le temps parle a vraiment
pas peur de rentrer c'est un chemin de
parler de position alors que kramnik
préfère lui plutôt en général les éviter
sacré travail beaucoup plus calme de ce
côté là il va pas chercher ce genre de
déséquilibres
j'ai vu comme nicklas néanmoins je vais
déjà ce genre de position avec tour
contre deux pièces il aime bien jouer ça
il comprend très bien aussi
enfin bien évidemment il a grandi
comprendra bientôt mais il a déjà joué
ce genre de truc qui ont l'air douteux
au départ c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression que les noirs sont bien
dans fait sait jamais si ça et là donc
alors une autre possibilité pour kramnik
aurait été alors il a pris l'adar
effectivement on va voir ça mais une
autre possibilité de jouer à 3 toujours
aller me dès que ce qu'on dit tout à
l'heure avec l'idée de prendre b4
évidemment les noirs ne peuvent pas me
prendre ni poussé puisque la dame et en
vis-à-vis et l'idée c'est de libérer
après prix comprend les tables de limit
cette tour face aux plans adverses et
d'activer au maximum ses pièces voilà
voilà une possibilité aussi qu aurait pu
faire kramnik mais bon il a choisi tout
simplement de prendre l'avion dans le
premier cas donc là tout est de forcer
quelque pratiquement d'un programme
d'emprunt dames et après il prend dame
travnik joué sur le fait que le roi est
coincé je peux leur fenêtre ou un très
bon regroupement ici enfin très
classique en même temps alors cavaliers
des cinq qui a été cinq magasins atac
lymphome attaque le fou donc ramené
garde le fou sur la diagonale un jour un
fou des six est maintenant un joli où
est l'arnaqué f5 empêche 4 donc ça
empêche le 4 qui aurait déstabilisé
celui cavaliers il va aussi et zadar où
il va pouvoir sortir sans gloire pour
libérer sa tour à le centre exactement
donc aucun doute que dans cette position
mais ce n'est pas le fêter plutôt
content de sa partie a été content de sa
partie déjà parce qu'il disait là je
peux jouer tous les gains dans une
position complexe et c'est ce que
cherche à faire exactement il semblerait
quand même que les noirs soient forcés
8,2 kramnik tentant de créer des menaces
des déblocages en tout cas et l'on va
assister en fait à une séquence où les
blondes savent vraiment pas trop quoi
faire
tout à fait non il patine un petit peu
ici qu'à l'aller 5 b 6 logique on
attaque la tour et on voit ce tour peut
pas rester sur le huitième puits ce qui
s'il est un pouce du cavalier et y en a
huit toujours en plus du quart et donc
il faut reculer et kramnik revient sur
la case c6 protégeant fou aux filles et
préparant sans doute le doublement des
tours en fait ce qu'il faudrait pour
venir tandis que c'est préparer
l'annoncé des pions à aider c'est à dire
essayer de créer un pion passé ici pour
crème font pas si les échanges et face à
ceux fixés ça avance et là où on a deux
contre un en profitant que les pièces
noires sont pas encore regrouper parce
que si on considère sur le long terme
on va voir comment je vais te bat loeb
c'était très fort des noirs pouces elle
allait droit et pousse ses pions g et h
ils essaient de voir une colonne par là
ils ont un droit qui est mieux protégé
des cavaliers au centre une très belle
position donc si ça se joue aux côtés ou
des quatre contre quatre
eh bien ça va être à l'avantagé des
noirs donc il faut que vladimir kramnik
secte ribes rapidement possède créé
soutien passé ouais tu as passé ici pour
créer faire diversion et empêcher noir
de masse et tout leur matériel qui est
plus nombreux ils ont plus de matériel
en nombre que les blancs tout simplement
quatre pièces contre 3 fouet cette tour
d un donc la logique aussi en active un
tourin qui jouait pas maintenant
relative à l'assemblée pour l'instant on
n'a rien fait pour créer ses pions ses
dix ans passés wife 7 et la tour c 7 la
tentative de là aussi on a l'impression
qu'il perd du temps craint munichois
impression qui perd du temps puisque
inactive pas cet arrêt de pions qui
pourrait jouer quand une activation plus
la prononcer ce n est pas si bien placé
que ça parce que il peut être amené à
chercher c'est bien mais tout simplement
est ce qu'un coup comme à 4 était pas
possible à quatre reprises
peut-être que ça marche le film est en
prise pour l'instant sur chiavenna
rimera 4 sur calais prend 1,4 on voit
bien que la maintenant tour c'est cette
marche puisque le qui ont été attaqués
voyons si on défend le pion par exemple
par tour à 8mn tout simplement fou prend
les selles
il ya eu 17 ans préseau stephen revenons
où le cavalier des services en marque
pas tout à fait non il faut défendre
l'image et des sept voiles et ça
marchera pas parce qu il faut prendre ou
après donc autour des micros mems dans
cette position tour des huit possibles
en pair à cette maladie grâce à la paire
à 7 et la partie resto compliqué d'abord
b3 pour attaquer le cavalier pas perdre
le pion et après cavaliers b6 on prend
1,7 et on a cent pour passer et vous
êtes vous passé maintenant voilà donc il
est quand même passé donc c'est loin et
c'est réussi
c'est quand même régime en place est bon
alors croyez pas il est pas super bien
passé il va avoir du mal à avancer quand
il est effectivement très probable dans
cette séquence en tout cas vladimir
kramnik n'a pas avancé ses pions assez
vite pour c'est cette part est un peu
lent et la tacle l'attaquent le pian il
était question va voir que voilà topalov
le tour à 820,8 donc ils activent sa
tour de l'autre côté pour défendre le
pion bon elle paraît passive ici mais
peut-être y vu jouer a sign je sais pas
pourquoi il mais ça pour la exactement
il veut simplement peut-être gardé le
pion ici et il ya quelque chose qui est
très important pour topalov c'est de ne
pas échanger sept tours justement ne pas
échanger une paire de tours il veut
garder des chances d'attac
il va voir avec tours et oui on dit
souvent dans ce genre de position que si
on a afit mende au tour contre une avec
les ces histoires de pièces en plus ils
voulaient changer la tour adverse exact
parce que les tours adverses travaille
très bien avec les pièces mineurs donc
on veut pas vous laisser d'échangé c'est
ça enlève de la puissance de feu donc
topalov pour l'instant n'appelle donc ne
peut pas occuper l'école ouverte parce
que kadima tram nickelés s'occupe
lui-même avec ses tours donc ils veulent
juste mettre sa tour sur un endroit peu
importe
attendre que d'autres colonnes s'ouvrir
ensuite activées à tourner mais il veut
surtout la chronique je vous tombez 7
alors là aussi on se demande encore ce
qu'il veut faire
on voit lui qui l'a qu'il a quand même
joué beaucoup de coups deux tours avec
avec sa tour et on sait pas trop ce qui
vient de faire un bep cette voie il est
également négligé aussi le son rôle
parce qu'on sait qu'on fine allyson
elwes qui pouvaient pas simplement je
vous rappelle andrew hall 2 wii voir f
3,3 f2 voilà au moins essayer
d'améliorer ses pièces alors que ce tour
bessette on ne va pas trop l'idée de la
lumière kramnik sa menace rien vous
allez me faire voyez on s'est un peu
fourvoyé en a l'impression quand même le
roi 8 de topalov lui ai alors topalov et
blanc création prévention il contrôle
bien la case 17 il protège bien ses
pièces une fois maintenant que la tour
est sorti il peut remettre son rang 8 et
la chronique faisait maintenant
d'échanger les pièces faut prendre cette
roue à prendre cet émetteur un tour sera
donc c'est l'idée de kramnik c'était ça
c'est m étonnante me trouver dans mes
sept jeux contrôler la colonne ouverte
avec ma tour mettait ce qu'il a sous
estimé c'est que c'est tour ne ferons
rien notation sur la 7e c'est facile à
contrôler ya une petite menace
stéphane c'est comme tour s'élance et 7
alors pour s' est un art imaginons un
coup comme halle 6 voilà par exemple
donc payer pour ses sept tours ces sept
on problème c'est qu'on attaque assalat
à cassettes et que c'est à défendre la
prescription pousse le pion à et bien
pour compliquer le dv6 par exemple à 6
ou à 5 on prend le cavalier du gua
joueurs du cahier 17 il faut que
topaloff
trouver une solution donc sur ce terrain
torcéen topalov anticipe anticipe et il
joue ensuite à 5 à 5
et il veut répondre maintenant au coût
de tours c'est cette force et cette tout
simplement par exemple par wade 6 ou roy
davis droit décès imaginons par exemple
pour ses sets
maintenant on va décider si c'est
simplement faire la fête il ya plutôt 30
tours puisque tous contrats liés puisque
lequel il prend tout est bien protégé en
fait ils viennent que le roi en
centre-ville ce roi est plus actif que
celui ci a oui ça c'est sûr donc ces
problèmes notre ami qu'il avait du bleu
et blanc maintenant pour topalov pousser
les pions gh1 ouvrir une colonne de
l'autre côté et placé sa tournée faire
ça tout refaire active et cesser de
cavale étonnant respect de tous en effet
clément dont villa il a virtuellement
une tour de plus ou presque avec une
pièce de plus en tout cas tout à fait à
leur tour ces six pour kramnik le dire
donc on voit bien qu'ils menaceront
camani voilà puisque ce quality cloud
est bon mais c'est une menace mais bon
on va pas trop d'ailleurs après
cavaliers des 5 il a on voit pas trop ce
qui peut faire mais non plus ce cavalier
empêche tour c'est cette donc il a
peut-être surestimé la la puissance de
ces tours le 10 mai rqra milk est oublié
qu'il avait du matériel qui jouait pas
notamment le roi et notamment ses deux
pions il s'est ni créer un pion pas ses
directives et son roi et a perdu du
temps on peut dire que on peut dire que
les droits ont un avantage déjà elle est
donc les noirs sont dans sa serre -
c'est certain d'ailleurs ça va ça va
arriver vite maintenant collection h&m
laurie h4 pour kramnik une tentative de
blocage alors tentative de blocage
adverse h6 pour topalov et après à 4
essayé de bloquer ce pion à 5 et a total
of c'est le moment pour g5 il a pas peur
maintenant crâne des coteaux pas leur
pardon crown of et le calife
je vais pas y arriver moi donc top à la
fin pas peur d'ouvrir les lignes au
contraire puisqu'il veut faire jouer sa
tour de plus tard il estime qu'avec ses
cavaliers notamment sukari centrale il
peut il peut créer des menaces face au
roi adverse le dire qu'en dit qu'il
était vraiment fait brillant sur
sur la séquence des dix derniers coups
il a vraiment rien fait du tout alors h
projet 5h projet c'est méthodes en bref
on a envie de dire c'est un peu tard go
c'est un peu tard déjà la colonne âge
s'est ouverte maintenant
topalov a encore pris l'initiative avec
ses pions les droits il a poussé sous
sections il continue il continue avec g4
voilà il crée on voit bien que c'est
l'une on voit bien qu'il veut attaquer
quand il veut se créer un pion passé et
il peut le faire puisqu'il a une pièce
de plus il peut il peut créer des
menaces dans le cas inverse il a pris 3
e 2 car les 5 m6 voilà donc il a ramené
son clavier soit 4,6 il va peut-être
venir sur la place de quatre probables
topalov pour peut-être joué g3 commencé
à créer des problèmes dans le camp blanc
mais il ne l'est peut-être déjà g3
d'ailleurs la semaine g3 tout de suite
alors après détroit pour crâner donc
qu'il veut et là il protège son curé
cloud pour les rsa pour la descente mais
il sait plus trop quoi faire
sait plus trop quoi faire et on voit
déjà que ya souci puisque ces deux tours
rapides cad pardon c'est alors que sept
tours déjà qu'on peut parler la papa lé
là non plus évidemment la pluie que
cette case ici où il ya 28 ans l année
commence à être un peu enfermé
suite à ce congrès 3 alors que avance
pour elle pouvait revenir en arrière
donc ça va ça va être un motif peut-être
d'attac alors après cavaliers à 8
donc là topalov replace ces pièces bon
c'est pas trop ce qu'il a il veut jouer
il veut jouer sur cette pauvre on va
jouer sur cette tournée voir c'est à
dire que là il faut commencer à jouer
cavalier des six attaques
je sais pas mais je dois avouer que j'ai
pas bien compris ce qui se passe dans
cette situation simplement vladimir
kramnik savait plus vraiment plus quoi
faire dans sa pression peut-être une
sorte de novlangue c'est possible qu'ils
étaient possibles c'est pas en tout cas
il a craqué semi craquer de jouer f3
wave 3 déjà acquis
quilès jouit g3 et on sait toujours ce
genre de coups et pénible puisque
maintenant d'avril très avancé il
contrôle des cases et il suffirait
d'enlever ce pion pour que ce plan ne
vienne énorme
exact donc c'est ainsi un gros souci
donc c'est aussi grâce à ce genre de
pions bien placé que des fois on peut
sacrifier sur f3 ce genre de choses
donc c'est un poison ce qu'on appelle un
poison dans le calme il n'a pas peur de
le perdre topaloff
il est avancé ses pions sert combat on
va essayer de bloquer d'ailleurs c'est
ce que fera kramnik on va le voir après
tour c'est un don qui on va me dire à
patrice et où il sait pas quoi faire
il peut rien faire face on sait que ces
cavaliers domine complètement toutes les
cases et après qu'a lieu le f6 donc
topalov revient maintenant kramnik tente
avec f4 ici dans l'échoppé le pion mais
en fait ils se trompent de plans
puisqu'en fait au peuple n'attend que ça
puisque sept tournois pouvoir après être
active sur cette colonne et notamment
les princes et voilà c'est le cas de la
case de cas très faible maintenant voilà
puisque le cavaliere c'est vraiment un
coup à jouer
la diva comme des rois des six devaient
déjà être déprimé complètement à ce
stade de la partie d'être dans un état
second
lumière parce que oui ça s'est passé
trop mal ces quinze derniers cool et
d'ailleurs il a dit c'est à dire la
conférence de presse que non mais
c'était pas un super jour pour vivre
n'est pas jouer les meilleurs coups
alors on va voir ce qui suit avec 3,3
donc sa part un bon groupe ce qu'on
apprend le pion mais on va voir que
sarah poser d'énormes soucis
après calais des cinq de topalov et
enfin la faute de kramnik à ce moment-là
roi penché 3 alors là c'est la faute
la faute décisives soit décisive 3 s'est
terminé de manière quasi forcée de
manière quasi forme et s'est terminé
alors qu aurait pu jouer kramnik
d'autres dans cette position toute façon
il était en difficulté et bien la
possibilité de jouer tour b5 aulas pour
éviter est possible et ne reviennent
immédiatement
alors hein ça évite que le conte
cavaliers viennent ici mais aussi ça
mais un oeil sur la casa 5 donc ça
empêche la tour de devenir là bas on
garde toujours un oeil sur sur les 3
donc c'est quand même beaucoup plus
actifs fin de colo j qui étaient ici de
prolonger veillée 7 9 6 alors il ya un
piège bien piégé loin c'est tour à sept
alors il faut bien analyser ça parce
qu'après tout à 7
on voit ce que je disais tout à l'heure
ça tourne à plus de 4 3 à 7 ans lève la
dernière case de la tour 6 et 17 donc on
va pouvoir cueillir à la tour avec
cavaliers c'est exact on va pouvoir
l'accueillir et on peut regarder tout de
suite qu est ce qui peut se passer en
fait le meilleur coût pour les blancs
ont été certainement de jouer le 4 et là
ici après qu'avait laissé cette voie là
la tour est prise au piège face à quel
piège alors là il fallait calculer sai
kramnik aurait pu s'en sortir en fait
pratiquer leur sport passion puisque
après je suppose que ça commence par eux
cinq échecs voilà il aurait fallu jouer
eux 5 et ses échecs et après roanne 7
eh bien il fallait sacrifier la
spécialité sacrifier la tour et après
tout reprend on prend à sec mais on a
deux pions pas s'il y est orné pièces de
moins mais on a quand même document
sinon c'était femmes c'est pato points 5
passes que sidya toure c3g alors donc
j'ai pas tout de suite ça alors je
pensais c'est
voilà c'est plutôt tourcoing sont
vraiment à 5 voilà un sacré cheval
portant à 5 pardon est d'accord c'est à
l'envers
rien de tout et on prend le cas les ici
voilà c'est mieux parce que la tour est
mal placée on a deux pions passé lié on
va accueillir ce pion exode et ya plus
que d'options échangés
parce que on peut faire du lot si on
peut faire nul le roi noir est mal placé
maintenant tout ce qui l'a enfermé le
roi est enfermé par le pion qui la
contrôle très bien donc ça va pas être
facile quand même pour les noirs alors
les noirs ont certainement encore
davantage grâce à la pièce de plus mais
il ya de grandes chances quand même de
deux nuls pour les blancs qu on va
prendre ce pion au prochain coup et
ensuite on va essayer de jouer g4 pour
le changer de camp f5 et après si on
arrivait à changer dernier pion là c'est
nul extraits donc voilà une plan pour
kramnik qu'il a peut-être raté
pas facile à calculer aussi on n'a pas
envie d'ouvrir une belle angèle vers
cette île nommée cheveux je pense
vraiment que là il a capitulé dans la
partie il ne pouvait vraiment plu parce
que je veux leur projet 3 c'est une
sorte d'abandon
c'est quelque part il abandonné parce
qu'après avoir plongé trois ça va trop
vite on peut regarder les coûts qui
suivent alors on va voir
ranger 3 maintenant on va voir ça c'est
la dernière faute de kramnik catégorique
avait laissé cinq est très fort avec un
tas de la tour gan temps et on va bondir
sur la case ou quatre oui ou alors on va
prendre le pétrole
on va prendre mais trois donc ce
cavalier énorme tout de suite
il prend toutes les cases donc kramnik
maintenant je cours g7 pour empêcher la
tour en fait d'être actif sur le roi
blanc parce qu'elle était tout rouge
évident puisque le club 04 il ya deux
cavaliers aussi parce que le pion aux 3
est en prise le deuxième khalife à venir
il y avoir des échecs de la tour donc ça
va être est horrible donc tour b8
tranquille de topal jeu ssl est typique
topalov et on voit bien que ce que tu
enseignes nombre est plus donc j'ai vu
prendre métro avec la tôt et il veut
prendre les trois pour ensuite ramasser
pour as à mettre dans toutes les pièces
d'autos club se déploie son superbe six
cavaliers ont la chronique c'est comme
si un peu kramnik a perdu cette partie
finalement oui exact exact mais alors
donc on peut la confondre avoir éteint
sur après tour à sept ans mais c'est un
peu tard maintenant pour à 7 est bien
une taxe sur notre colonne échec et
après roy f3 cavaliers eux quatre ces
horribles puisque maintenant le tour
j'ai 3 arrive avec le roi qui bouge et
ensuite tout reprend g2 et on est dans
un réseau de maths à cause des deux
cavaliers il souhaite d'autres le cinéma
dans tous les sens on va le voir tour à
6 échecs ans le 7
on prend le pion donc ça c'était un
petit échec pour quand même éloigné le
roi noir du théâtre des opérations
et après tout rejet trois échecs roi eu
deux tours prend 1,3 donc on va déjà que
ça saute qui à tout qui saute alors par
exemple ce roi des huns peut-être le
montrer au bras d un don il ya plusieurs
possibilités notamment on peut jouer par
exemple pour prendre les trois avec
indien technique facile au premier plan
mais aussi qu'avaient les premières
catégories l'oeuvre est horrible ça fait
quand même deux carrier qui sont qui
sont en forme et sont exercés cavaliers
et le clocher 2 va tomber aussi voilà en
fait c'est vraiment horrible mais bon on
préfère peut-être prendre le pouls des
droits de l'homme et 3 passes comme ça
on est tranquille parce qu'ils
repasseront j'en ai d'autres et céline
on refuse rien c'est la fin alors
kramnik a choisi donc encore trois
échecs il a choisi le roi est fin et
après tout reprendre mes trois tours à
cet échec il peut plus rien faire c'est
inéluctable ou réussissent le renoir est
parfaitement sécurisée les plus de
cochrane et donc ils tentent encore de
venir manger car étions passés je vais
le pouce et si tu te rends tu préfères
dame pour un 8 mai topalov il a tout vu
car les pros f4 et c'est déjà un mois
que c'est car ils sont énormes
puisqu'ils contrôlent toutes les cases
ici pardon c'est pas là mais c'est ici
toutes les cases ici devant le roi dans
quelle ville de matane et de la tourbe
arrivé pour aider la tour va arriver
et après tout round kramnik tourbe et de
et ça y est je pense qu on a déjà un
réseau de maths
ici c'est le stylo par le matin et les
maths est imparable
enfin à moins de donner toutes les
pièces mais ce qui compte vraiment ce
qui connaît un match plus tard donc à 5
et après tout rêve de ces matches on va
le voir on peut le voir les deux matches
possibles kramnik abandonne encore
montré l'image
après re 1 donc là il ya maintenant 2
elle est tout simplement cavaliers
detroit qui est très joli cahier trois
chèques échec revient en d'eric et ses
trois matchs alors on peut mater du
cavalier ou de la tour ou de la tour à
tour ici de les deux fondamentaux
messieurs est très seul est très jolie
ville mais sympathique parce que là on
voit qu'ils aillent chèque et le roi
donc peut pas monter à cause de la tour
et peut pas aller sur les côtés à cause
ici des cavaliers donc voilà donc ces il
est complètement coincé petit réseau de
macho millions voilà sinon tour aussi
tour des deux matches c'est le même cela
sinistre des épaules est sûre il y
aurait protégé par le cavalier et lors
de l'autre côté
donc c'est rare qu'on ait des maths à ce
niveau là donc oui il ya un brin grand
donc là ton échec note wave 2 donc sergé
1 / wajeha messier saura exactement la
même touché 2 voilà on revient à l
abstinence ima tanggu exactement tous
rêvent de on revient donc on vient de
voir le match qui sur la gauche dont
combat maintenant sur la droite le coeur
n'est plus là voilà donc ce cavalier h
trois échecs ou qui avaient lieu deux
les deux n'importe lequel des échecs
force le roi à partir sur la case
matérias trois échecs 3h 1 est bien
léger trois échecs et mat car les
jetteront un échec et mat ses superbes
donc très bien joué de la part de
topalov mais on peut dire qu'on avoir
l'impression ses chroniques et fatigué
mais c'est ce qu'on avait prévu en début
de match aussi y sait que c'est la
stratégie de topalov qui porte un peu
ses fruits parce que topalov depuis le
début il veut jouer toutes les parties à
fond il joue de la joue physique donc ça
lui a coûté cher dans les premières ou
blé de mire tandis qu'ils étaient bien
en forme bien sharp il calculé
des clercs et calculez bien il a joué en
contre et il a gagné deux parties mais
sur la fin d'année vient maintenant
vladimir et commence à être un peu plus
fatigué topalov il est un peu plus chaud
s'ajoutent à ça l'ambiance générale du
match ah non mais là c'est stalair une
pression de folie sur le dit mercredi
ce qui fait que maintenant venir kramnik
se départir en demi teinte
je dirais même pas demi teinte racines
partie mais aura quand même fille qu'on
voit sur une impression et loi que ce
match a basculé avec 7,7 plainte de
l'équipe topalov complètement infondées
un peu et c est que là on arrive quand
même un dénouement qui est presque parce
que ce que voulait le plan topaloff est
bien celle des granitiers de tomber dans
un piège là au score c'est l'égalisation
un officiel en tout cas officiellement
l'égalisation avec un kramnik atteint au
moral c'est clair que la dina tandis
qu'il est là c'est clair celui des
blessés il est fatigué mais il s'est
tapé les conférences de presse à se
justifier qu'ils voulaient pas jouer
parce qu'on lui avait fermé ses
toilettes des trucs complètement
invraisemblable je n'aurais pas dû il
n'aurait pas dû et donc il est fatigué
parce que l'autre il est là sur
l'échiquier lui met la pression et
besoins et sur la fin de match va être
très dur pour les dernières escales
partie il reste que quatre parcs salaire
en cas d'égalité
en cas d'égalité il ya des tie break oui
en partie rapide ce qui serait
intéressant
alors à bientôt pour suivre la suite de
ce championnat du monde si vous écoutez
bien les parties suivantes
on sait pas aujourd'hui évidemment
combien de partir est aujourd'hui
puisqu'on enregistre le premier 6 et
demi
gagne le match donc ça peut s'arrêter
naturellement mais il aussi avoir des
forfaits ou d'autres événements on peut
y avoir des choses 1 voilà il reste
quatre parties voilà à bientôt
oh